in five four three two one
what's up you silly silly stupid sons of
[ __ ] how you guys doing today we have
a very very special guest I'm talking
about the light-skinned princess from
Virginia I'm talking about the silky
head straighten this book bosey
Billington you know you complimenting my
hair is the best compliment I love did I
ever tell you about the one time that I
almost push back my cheek a news shoot
because I bought cheap weave and I was
like you got the 999 peg dude yes super
serious I was like okay well yeah I
suppose think I have the text message
where I texted TIFF and I was like is
David over yet I can still make it
oh my god I'm serious I'll send it to
you out of this - I don't have cloud on
you already taking you aside as like you
going like what's going on like you got
yeah looks fantastic I [ __ ] love it
are you all professionally [ __ ] I don't
like this I don't like you dressing all
professional with the [ __ ] button up
you look all adult and [ __ ] I don't know
I don't like it though you see you got
your titties out you [ __ ] I know
normally it was like overnight - you
know I in like seriously I put bows in a
bag like when I got when I got the new
like wardrobe because like the office I
work at now it's like it like there's a
bunch of attorneys that work there is
very buttoned up and corporate like not
like there's a lot of places in LA that
it's like you work in Santa Monica you
can wear sweatpants and one [ __ ]
flip-flop you know yeah yeah yeah like
they're they they're old school so I
kind of had to conform to that but like
I like it and so you're you're like
straight up straight up corporate
corporate oh yeah like could not LA
corporate it's like corporate corporate
that's wild to me because like I feel
like everybody who went on a social
media platform decided to go away from
that and then you are so successful on
that platform and then you said [ __ ] it
like usually people are bad at
[ __ ] and then they disappeared you know
saying but you're successful like not
all not only do you have the personality
for you got the looks for it you got the
whole possess or whatever [ __ ] white
people say I've never heard anyone from
any race I don't know I think that's I
think that's a Jewish sorry but you know
what go on yeah like you had like the
whole thing going for you and like I
just decided like I remember just
reading a tweet and you're like yeah you
know this corporate does a corporate job
a corporate job I started like this okay
this is like the wack thing I'm gonna
tell you I started writing in a grateful
journal like a gratefulness journal okay
you know and it helps me get more
positive cuz I always used to be like a
super negative person and like that that
[ __ ] is so last year like I'm over it
you know but one of the things I thought
about I was like damn somebody must have
been really mean to me in high school
because I went from being a cast member
on a YouTube channel with like seven
million subscribers to just being a
marketing director in Beverly Hills like
in just a few weeks like and I was like
this is sick and I'm just gonna write it
out like I I can't believe it like I'm
kind of proud of myself but also I'm
like damn I was like somebody was mean
to me that's what it was really like
you're on me now you're on the opposite
end of the people that I have to deal
with right because you're a marketing
director so it's like it's it's
completely well at least you have
experience in a new in the new media
world yeah which we basically are which
is kind of what but you know what though
like it's good to have you on that side
because you do have social media
experience right and you know what's on
the side cuz usually what happens is
when we deal with people who are
marketing directors they assume what
it's like on this side yeah and that's
and you know that's something that I've
that I've been dealing with because I I
work with like a lot of attorneys and
stuff right now and basically my plan is
to hop into this industry you know just
get my hands dirty understand it you
know I got my title we're building the
resume and then I'll probably return to
entertainment but still stay on the
marketing and like you know see sweet
side so like oh yeah so you're thinking
about doing a comeback oh I'm oh I'm
coming back okay yeah
so wild like I don't know if like well
this is my comeback right so if I quit
let's say if I quit doing YouTube right
then I just had to go back to working at
a black beauty supply store which is my
fallback is way different than yours
well okay we are we going right into
like how this even happen yes because
that's what I really want to do I'm just
I'm just chopping it up just to hear the
[ __ ] but I really have you here
because there is some [ __ ]
[ __ ] drink and spilt I mean just as a
precursor just to let everybody know let
them know who you are what you did
before prior to being a marketing
director okay okay well so I started out
I started out actually even rewind fat
like further I was bartending in
Virginia and then I decided I'm gonna
bartend in Vegas I didn't like Vegas and
so then I went back to Virginia and I
started streaming on Twitch I they say
strip it and I was like whoa oh but my
roommate she was a stripper and like it
started to become normalized to me and
it kind of scared me because I was like
if I stay here longer I'm gonna fall
into this lifestyle because when you're
around it a lot it's like it's like your
morals just get kind of like I'm not
saying that it's like moralist to do
that but like your values to say value
my vows your personal value my personal
values and like the longer I was around
it I was like damn I'm gonna fall into
this and I didn't want to fall into that
so yeah you know in Vegas I was just
getting wasted every night and like you
know just hanging out with people that
weren't the best and so I decided to
leave and went back to Virginia I didn't
really know what to do and I started
streaming on Twitch cuz I've been I've
been playing video games since I was
like god I don't even know like yeah
forever that was my thing you know
online I just like escape to playing
video games because I was like very
rejected by people for a lot of my life
so suddenly you cannot yeah you know you
can just pop online and these people
don't know what you look like they don't
know what you're about they just they
just accept you if you're good at the
game they accept you and you know for a
person that had horrible self-esteem I
gained my IQ I gained a lot of my self
esteem just by being good at these games
and getting better at these games
because that's how I learned how people
accept me yeah and so gaming is
very very like close to me it like built
the foundation for kind of who I was and
so it was kind of natural for me to
start streaming on Twitch I want to say
like in 2014 so I did that for a while
and like one day I get like a call from
this company and they're like hey we
like what you're doing you want to come
out to LA and do this out here and it
was it was just like a direct line yeah
yeah they hit me up and I was like okay
so I went through like two auditions and
eventually they were like oh this is for
Smosh and like I it up and obviously cuz
I knew what it was but like I hadn't
really kept up with it and I was like oh
you guys do on it's game trailers like
there was a whole cast behind it in this
whole thing so you know I went through I
went through I did all the auditions and
then you know I made the cut and I moved
out to LA and I joined Smosh um and it
was tight it just hey like it like I
call it serendipity because it came out
of nowhere so you just like you just up
and [ __ ] leave [ __ ] ha you just [ __ ]
it what's that what's that say you throw
caution to the wind you just know I
don't think I would have done it if I
didn't come out to LA with a salary you
know oh yeah yeah like because you know
I'm not ballsy like that I have anxiety
David you know um so yeah I joined Smosh
I joined Smosh wait I left Smosh I mean
there was a lot to happen with the
company but the company you know the
channel itself was still being sold and
you know as far as I know everyone is
still on board huh yeah I mean the quick
background to is like Smosh went through
this whole thing where they just well
basically they were supposed to
disappear because they what the company
the parent company of Smosh filed for
bankruptcy they had a they had an
investor that last minute kind of looked
at their credit and looked at like you
know what was going on with the company
and they pulled out on this massive
investment and then suddenly the company
couldn't make payroll yeah they but I
mean they had they made some like I'm in
my opinion I felt like they made some
bad business decisions as far as like
they had an office in Times Square in
office in San Francisco and office in
Chicago
Iren in Times Square each each room had
like personalized wallpaper if it was
your office you could pick your own damn
wallpaper you know so yeah so the parent
company called the five media they went
bankrupt you hear all that [ __ ] with
like Shane Dawson and Matt Pat and all
that no yes Matt Pat said the defy so
basically before we get to UM why I left
Smosh so Matt Pat made a video where he
was saying that defy was trying to sell
all of its assets including Smosh
because they knew that it was going
under but it was an MCN so they were
collecting money from other channels
like like game theorists like Shane
Dawson's Rylan Rylan Adams channel like
the MCN was like hey a hundred percent
of your check goes to us we take 10% we
protect you from copyright you know a
lot of other stuff we promote your
channel and then we send you the 90%
well before the company shut down they
held everyone's checks for two months to
make the company look more profitable
yeah and and then the company shut down
and nobody got their money what the yeah
all those youtubers didn't get their
adsense it was about 2 million dollars
of Adsense do you see this is why I'm
saying this is why I stay poor because
poor people don't let a deal with none
of these [ __ ] promise yeah like if
I'm expecting a check for like $100,000
now don't get it that's one things I'm
telling you right now you guys think I'm
[ __ ] knows because I choose to stay poor
that's [ __ ] wild how did it that's so
amazing I mean I know it's a bad story
but it's kind of amazing how like a
couple of youtubers got to a point where
their company blew up that [ __ ] big
but it was only because define media
bought them outright it was their influx
of money no they notify was like it was
define was like a startup Smosh I
believe was its first acquisition and it
used the name Smosh to get other
channels to join its MCN oh yeah that's
that's kind of I feel like that's kind
of how a lot of these MCN started right
with uh with with the one that was sold
to Disney maker yeah it was something
ridiculous and then when Disney guys
they're like no no no and then they open
the box in there there was nothing in
there yeah [ __ ] disappear yeah I mean
but that's that's that's the thing it's
like it's a whole new industry new media
is a whole new industry so there's ways
that you can swindle your way around
doing
certain things you know because there's
not a lot of laws and regulations in
place
people hate laws and regulations but
they don't understand that not everyone
is a good or smart person and they'll
[ __ ] you over and that's why those
regulations are in place yeah I mean
especially when it came to that that
whole acquisition like slowly you
started to realize specifically like
people in Disney I felt like they're
very old-fashioned like even the way
that I know people who work at Disney
and how they run things it's still very
old-fashioned and then you get this
social media thing coming on and they're
like oh we know how to run this no you
don't yeah they're like let's just buy
one cuz like we got we got you know
forty billion dollars let's just throw
like a few million at this and see what
happens
I mean to them it's nothing you know
it's like okay well they what are they
own [ __ ] Star Wars
they won't Marvel they own [ __ ] they
own everything that I mean still I
wouldn't even know what to do with five
hundred million dollars right like just
like it puts me into a panic you know I
would be irresponsible oh for sure I
would be irresponsible but even my
irresponsibility I can't even think
about how much money I could spend
because the type of money I would spend
I would just walk down every street find
everybody I don't like and slap the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of him cuz you can't
cuz you got money and throw cash in
their face and they see what happens
just slap is like why'd you do that
here's ten thousand dollars shut the
[ __ ] up I want to get slapped
exactly you wouldn't - [ __ ] if somebody
slapped my face if somebody whipped out
their huge dick and they just used it as
chapstick for my lips and they went like
that and they're like ten thousand
dollars I was like you know what dude it
was worth it and I go home right but
like like and you were just talking
earlier about like how you don't mind
being disrespected I mean a man -
somebody just walking up to you and just
slapping the [ __ ] out of you but then
they hand you money oh then I'm not
disrespected that was a trades of good
that was a barter system that's what we
did right there we traded goods alright
his self-esteem went up and my bake
count went up it's all good that's true
that's true well I mean it's a it's a
shaky thing but we gotta know why you
left Smosh though that's that's that's
you know oh I got a no I got it because
she has been hyping me up about I want
to say hyping up but like
I'm gonna save it for the podcast yeah
because I haven't I haven't like talked
to her in a minute
and obviously is because you've been
working like a regular job I expect you
to come back on on JK news obviously JK
news has a very weird schedule yes
impossible so I mean I I can't
eventually but it's just like you know
it was easier cuz like we can like do
the podcast after hours but yeah I'm JK
soon but I have a story I was gonna say
for JK by my ex Billy here but we'll get
to that later
oh so alright so why I left Smosh
alright but I'm actually gonna tell you
I'm definitely I'm gonna tell you and
you you just you just went no I'm
licking my lips like I saw a [ __ ]
stack of ribs alright so we got a little
bit of tea but also like just some real
a [ __ ] yeah some real a [ __ ] yeah so um
okay
so some people that you know some people
watch Smosh I know a lot of like JK like
David fans and stuff but there was a
there was a video that we put out we
filmed in December I want to say of 2017
yeah and watch people this this video we
were like thank you for watching Smosh
it's just like it's really cringey but I
had to like let them know like what the
video was okay so it was like that video
and in the video they lined up all of
the cast in the front and then they were
putting staff like the whole staff of
Smosh in the background and we kind of
were like in Christmas Carol formation
right yeah
and so the cast was lined up first and
so we were sitting there for about 20
minutes while they lined everyone up and
um I had this revelation because I was
sitting there and I was surrounded by I
want to say there was about 11 or 12
people in the cast at the time I was
looking around and I was like these are
some good-looking talented funny kids
yeah and there's 12 of us and we're not
all gonna make it yeah like that's just
some real [ __ ] and I had to step back
for a second I was like it's ambitious
to think that even one of us is gonna
make it and be successful in this field
battling out with everyone in Los
Angeles and so I asked myself three
questions basically I was like do I have
the connections to make it out here in
LA do I have the drive to be the top of
the entertainment industry and you know
do I have the skill to do so um and and
like this was all happening in that
video like before the video was shot cuz
I was like deep in it because I was like
damn you know and I and I was like well
I've lived in LA for a year so I
definitely don't have the connections
I've been a gamer for like ten years
I've just been coasting you know and
this and this opportunity fell on my lap
I was not here like going and get it I
haven't been putting out content for
years and you know dreaming I'm having
my name in lights so I didn't have the
drive and then on top of that I haven't
perfected my comedy as a craft and I've
never tried to do so I find myself to be
entertaining but I'm not necessarily an
entertainer so for me to go across the
board and say no to all three of those
questions was really enlightening
because I was like I don't think that
this is gonna be my industry I don't
think that this is for me and you know
if I do become successful in it I'm not
gonna take that away from someone who is
fighting for it and has been fighting
and dreaming for this for their whole
life well you're a really nice person I
don't even think about it like that I'm
like listen I think all this opportunity
I'm gonna take this from some
[ __ ] guess what guess what you
didn't jump on his stupid [ __ ] I just
knew that I didn't it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't my top priority and another
thing about me is you got to stick to
your values and my values tell me that I
have to be the best at what I'm doing I
have to be excellent it's very important
for me to be you know in the top 5%
Japanese like what are you doing I have
to be accurate if I don't become
excellent I have to kill myself with a
separate goodnesses the sword to the
stomach I mean and that's what it was
because like you don't I mean some
people I how do I explain it like I'm
very competitive
okay I'm very very competitive so I if
I'm in the top 45 percentile which is a
sustainable entertainment career you're
still successful you're still making
money you're still making moves it's not
I'm not happy with myself
I have to do better and to enter a field
that I'm not really in control of my
success was kind of scary to me and it
just wasn't my jam you know I wasn't
about it so so after I realized that
that was in
17 I started trying to look for ways
within the company to build my resume
because I wanted to stick out in LA you
know I wanted to make it work and and I
had like a boss that was like oh yeah
well I can help you career path into
marketing well like weeks or months and
I realized that wasn't happening so I
started trying to create shows that I
could put on my resume and and I and I
made like - I made one show that was
like kind of funny whatever and then I
came out with this court parody show
that did insanely well you know the
channel went from getting like 200,000
views per video to like this series was
getting 1 million like constantly yeah
people love that [ __ ] and so I was
really excited about it and I was like
damn I can put this on my resume I'm
producing in show running and so right
before the company shut down I was in
the middle of getting this really
[ __ ] fantastic survival for survival
survivor style game shows approved where
it was just all the cast mates and we
were gonna start voting each other off
over [ __ ] it was like drama it was games
it was it was funny it was so good it
got greenlit we were going through we
were starting to figure out where to put
product placement and stuff like that
this [ __ ] was happening and then the
company shut down like out of nowhere I
was a little nervous at first because my
resume was not where I wanted it to be I
thought that I had like another year
there and they told us we're not getting
paid we're not getting paid severance
we're not getting paid out for the next
two months and and on the Wednesday that
I was told this we were told we may not
have even been getting paid for Monday
and Tuesday that we had just worked
because the CFO had quit it was just out
of left field so like my brain went into
like panic mode it was like all right
what do we do I went home I wrote the
[ __ ] resume the day we got that
letter and I started looking and then
about the first week that I started
looking so I would say this was around
like November 6th okay the first week I
started looking I realized okay I have a
producer resume I went on to this
website to like look for producer things
in the first couple months I saw up
there were 20 years experience master's
degree in film producer of this blah
blah blah blah blah and almost like I'm
not competing with this I was like we're
not doing this this is not gonna work
and I'm not gonna sit here and struggle
it were like I can struggle or I can set
myself up
you know I'm not swimming in a sea of
actors I'm not swimming in a sea of
producers I'm just not doing it so I
just I took a look at everything that I
had as a whole and what skills I had and
I was like I have some digital media
experience I have some marketing
experience I need to find a company that
needs to make the switch to digital and
hasn't yet because they need me just as
much as I need them yeah and that's what
I did
damn that's [ __ ] bosses [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] survivor dude I went into this
company and I went in as the digital
marketing manager and I think within
like 40 41 days I took over the
marketing department what off what yeah
and you made me feel like a piece of
[ __ ] don't you ever meet my parents
don't you [ __ ] dare well you you you
you sit there you just be a stereotype
all right that's what you need to do you
sit there on a [ __ ] porch with a
piece of wheat coming out to now like
you know I had a minute like not to suck
my own dick or anything but I had a
minute we're like I got a letter from
Kurt for Christmas from my grandparents
and it had the address of where we used
to live and I realized and I never
thought about this and like there's some
people that are like well I can't I
can't make it here because this is how I
was raised this is my situation I saw
the address of where at the house I grew
up in and I just decided to google it
because you know nostalgia yeah and I
decided to google it and I saw the house
posting for it and I realized that I
grew up in a thousand square foot house
with six people and I just never thought
anything of it like in the countryside
in Virginia I never thought anything of
it like that's where I'm from that's
where I was raised until I was like I
don't know like eight years old or
something
yeah then we moved to a city but like
that's that's where I came from and I
never thought about that I never let it
stop me and like imma just keep [ __ ]
rolling that's crazy though but youryour
idea of like just continuing to roll on
it's not just rolling on though you're
trying to master a craft and that is
hard to do and it's very hard for me to
explain people like for example even
starting this podcast right people don't
understand what it means to really do
something because you really want to be
great at something or because you enjoy
it people look at success as
just numbers right so how much money are
you making alright
or they'd see it in the value of what
other people think about what you're
doing they go oh well why'd you do this
because you were being you were more
successful in that well who says who
says who you're not in my shoes you're
not living my life you're not gonna have
to wake up with these choices that you
make every day but I do yes I have to
wake up knowing the fact that I'm very
unhappy just because you see this like
external success it doesn't I don't [ __ ]
with it I could give a [ __ ] less what
you think about how successful I am I
gotta believe it right so we got to wake
up and we got to live with these choices
and that's pretty amazing because like
for me even on the outside even though I
say this I was like this [ __ ] lost her
[ __ ] mind [ __ ] a corporate job but now
that we talk it makes sense right
because in my mind I assume that that
the entertainment was like the only path
that you really wanted to go to but
that's not really the case no I just you
know it's it is served me and it served
me incredibly well yeah and it was it
was an incredible part of my life and
you have to you have to choose the next
right step for you yeah and you know I I
think the reason why I initially I
gravitated towards entertainment was
because I was very insecure and I
thought that if people liked me I would
like myself and you know I had a point
where I had a hundred thousand followers
on Instagram and I was so excited and I
realized that I still [ __ ] hated
myself yeah nothing had changed it's
nothing but a vanity metric so I had to
do a lot of soul-searching and figure
out why I was so unhappy and why I
thought you know these things about
myself and why I was looking for
external validation and and then in
that's a realization a lot of people
don't get to come to because they don't
get to see those numbers and realize
that they're all empty
you know and I mean they're definitely
there definitely is a lot of love in a
very supportive community but nothing
nothing fulfills you as much as patting
yourself on the back finally like that
if you've never done that before it's so
much more fulfilling yeah external
validation is very fleeting too because
people's opinions about you change
constantly oh yeah they do
all the time they love you one day they
[ __ ] hate you the next so how can you
base how you feel about yourself about
what other people say about you when
they don't even know what the [ __ ]
they're saying about you - exactly
they'll love you one day they'll hate
you they'll be whatever about you
they'll be like okay well now I love you
again it's like I can't I can't sit here
and wait for you to tell me what my
value is because this is this is just
stupid I haven't figured out for myself
yet you know and that's the hard part -
especially with men I read this I don't
know I think he's a gay whose name is
ninja or something I don't know about
the gang but somebody one of my friends
retweeted what he said and the reason
why he retweeted he wanted me to see it
it's because he wrote this it was
something along the lines of when he sat
he goes sometimes when I said I liked I
like to go look back at my old comments
to make me feel better that that's what
he tweeted and then people [ __ ] with
that they were little had a [ __ ] [ __ ]
ton of retweets and I'm like who is that
the [ __ ] is that how you live like
when you're sad you look back at people
sucking your [ __ ] dick to make
yourself feel better you know what
that's a that's a mentality that
sometimes has a slow rise or it has an
overnight rise yeah and I feel as a
person that realized that you know that
this external validation was not my jam
you know like I feel like we kind of got
the slow rise we got to see the ups and
downs of it over the years as it came
for people that have the overnight thing
well suddenly their brain switches and
they have to have the external success
because everyone's watching them and it
sucks to be in an age where everyone can
see how successful you are with numbers
yeah
it's not it's not fair because then you
feel this pressure to raise those
numbers when like you said those numbers
are not really indicative of success it
becomes like a person's value metric it
dies and people can antagonize you on
your value metric like it's weird cuz
they like I feel like I should not even
feel like I've seen this but a lot of my
friends younger kids right
they literally base their group of
friends on how many followers they have
their interactions on Instagram and they
become the popular kids through that
type of thing which is so [ __ ] weird
it's it was already hard enough when we
were in school right so it's like the
popular kids or whatever but now there's
an actual [ __ ]
number that you can see to place value
on you as a human being
oh can you imagine being in high school
and having Instagram right now look I
would cry oh for sure I would cry
somebody probably would have posted a
story of me eating my lunch in the
bathroom they go to my page and like
there's like two selfies with with one
what like zero likes in one comment it's
like hey you [ __ ] nerd yeah it's
pretty bad like I don't get it like it's
it's one of the things like like I um
I'm starting to think now where I had a
conversation with my girlfriend and I
asked her you know when we have a kid
because we have a lot of our friends
they post their children up on social
media right but there's somebody who
doesn't do it that's very popular KC
nice day KC nice that only shows the
back of the head of his kid hmm right he
doesn't want people to know our identity
yeah and and there's like two signs it's
two sides to that right it's like well I
had this child why can't I just share
the joy that I have with this kid these
are memories yeah but then Michael my
other side of the coin is why do you
need other people to see your memories
that's you know that yeah so for me it's
like I understand that there's value in
having your kid there right like let's
be real like when you win a lot of
people like Yuma Barton Joe Barton Gio
not Joe Barton Gio right like they want
to share the love of their kid right and
I completely [ __ ] with it it's
absolutely amazing but if somebody asked
me if I wanted to do that with my own
kid I don't know not because of maybe
you know maybe not for us so much for
the kids sake too but also for my sake I
don't know if I can put my kid out there
for that like cuz even though like I'm
on a social media space I'm actually
very very private okay
I'm super yeah like I have a lot of
[ __ ] opinions I'll tell a lot of my
personal stories that I'm okay telling
and there's a lot of [ __ ] stories but
there's still that 30 or 40 percent
that's very reserved that nobody will
ever hear that [ __ ] you know unless it's
like off camera or something else you
know and for me like to have my kid on
that thing makes me a little worried
it's really personal yeah yeah that's
like the most person like that's so
personal and then I'm already putting
the value metric on that kid before they
even get to decide for themselves I'm
saying here well
this is who you are as a person you're
connected to me you're gonna have X
amount of followers this this and this
and this is gonna be your life and I'm
already setting in stone before I'm
allowing this kid to develop who they
are as a person and that's what scares
me
and these aren't facts by the way this
is just my thoughts and opinions the
stuff that I'm worried about is somebody
who doesn't have a kid yet no and I mean
like I I totally get it because it has
to do with you know like your values
like what you you know if part of your
value is being a private person whereas
some people you know that's not a part
of their values yes it's different yeah
it's totally different yeah I just don't
want like I'm like I'm scared of like
just because I see kids like breaking
under that type of pressure and for them
to already be attached to a I guess a
quote-unquote semi popular human being
and then had that space girl from that
it's just it's just a weird thing you
know I feel like I'm already I'm already
setting their their destiny now before
they even have a chance to write their
own and that's the part that [ __ ]
scares me enough plus I don't want my
kid to be a little [ __ ] [ __ ] either
I mean seriously because well if you
start if you start him off with all
those followers he's gonna go to his
head from the beginning and he will
never know what it's like to not base
his own value on a metric yeah I'll
never know
like about me but at the same time your
kid might get pissed if you didn't share
any of those followers and he's gotta go
to school and now you can take kids out
like 23 follow that's nobody likes him
i'ma jump I'm at school then how about
that and they're gonna be like oh [ __ ]
he got jumped by David so that kid looks
like he's 40 years old I love I could
dress up with the over all the little
[ __ ] spinning thing on the top it's
like 40 girls won't even dress like that
that's a three color suspenders but
that's also where [ __ ] with you David
because like you and actually you know a
lot of oh no here it's coming but they
say what you see I I feel a lot of like
genuineness and warmth between like you
and like you know like other people that
are in JK yeah I was at Smosh for two
years and it was just cold every day oh
wow every single day like I mean I think
that I think that coming into that this
is a you know this is
all of them but some of them this is a
very tightly knit group of people that
have been friends for five years yeah
you're not gonna just walk in and be
their friend um and you know I think
early on I think I was kind of weird I
was socially awkward I'm sure I was
unprofessional like these people are
very very professional like super savvy
business folks and I just I was just a
kid they came in and you know I learned
a lot there but I feel like I was never
forgiven for some of the socially
awkward you know nice that I had and you
know even looking back I'm like oh that
was kind of cringe e'er that was that
but you know I never wronged anyone and
like what like what would you do
oh I mean like I don't know I feel like
I would just like do embarrassing stuff
or like I was like unprofessional or
would speak at the wrong time or like
you are unprofessional at a place called
Smosh yeah it's it's all it's all
business dawg it's all business
that's so weirdly yeah because I think
that after let's see the company had a
falling out in November a person there
that I'm actually pretty good friends
with but other than that I've gotten two
text messages from them I got a happy
birthday from one person and I got a
another hey I just wanted to let you
know this is you know this is what's
going on with Smosh I hope you're doing
well and that's it that's so weird
because like even in a corporate setting
right and like in a corporate setting
like my girlfriend she worked in a
corporate setting after she moved from
her job to the next where she's working
a new job now she still keeps in contact
with the people that she connected with
like they still hit her up they get
lunch together that there's a connection
asked after the job so like it's it's
kind of odd that and it's even more
weird from a place that started from
YouTube because like you've been with JK
right like all of us you have a huge
family mentality yeah exactly and like I
felt that from you know I worked with
you guys before everyone to your studio
and the day that I sat down in your
studio I was like oh this this is warm
this feels like home these people are
these people are real and it kind of
sucked too you know to go into a place
every day and not feel that warmth when
you had to put that warmth on on camera
yeah and you know it sucked to come in
on a Monday and hear about some event or
some party or some house party or just
something that was going on that
you didn't know about because you
weren't invited that's so what the [ __ ]
that don't [ __ ] weird man
um and you know I spent a lot of time
and I was like okay well it's me like
I'm weird like I'm just [ __ ] weird
I'm a weird person and to this day I'm
not you're not weird you were just in a
sea full of Qaeda it was all business
and I I'm like a puppy dog like I wanted
like I wanted more like I wanted
friendship like I wanted like I'm very
I'm a very vulnerable person and I'm
happy to open myself up and I had
several times where and I think that's
another thing too I think sometimes you
know if there was some kind of issue or
conflict I would put my heart on the
table and it was just very cold and I
learned you don't do that in business
you you can't be real with people this
is not a friendship this is this is a
business yeah and but you know in in
that kind of sense yeah but not so not
so true though because there are still
companies that run outside it just
YouTube right like an animation in
production right emotions do matter
that's why they have a [ __ ] HR
people's emotions do [ __ ] it matter
there are connections that are being
built at these companies yeah so
whatever Smosh was doing in the
background that made you feel that way
in my personal pain like I said I don't
know them on a personal scale but me
that's that's not that's on that's on
them that's their company culture then
because if they're thinking yeah I
understand I a hundred percent agree
businesses business right but when
you're doing something with like along
with production TV and stuff like that
staff morale is huge yes so [ __ ] big
but that's the thing they were close I
was not a part of that circle and there
there was a few circles hmm but I was
not part of that circle and I never felt
welcome let me ask you something how
many black people did Smosh they got rid
of my boy and then and then cuz he was
too dark I know that's what happened
they said they call me they called him a
living shadow
they said this [ __ ]
I'm kidding but no I mean yeah there was
a it would not it was I don't know I
guess I'm just [ __ ] weird I think
you're weird though like I know weird
because there's okay so this is what it
is there's different categories of weird
right alright you're fun weird right
you're it's called quirky so you don't
say of course you're [ __ ] like I like
I'm the [ __ ] metric for normal though
I'm secretly like just a giant puppy dog
that's what I am well that's what I'm
saying like you're there's there's weird
and then there's [ __ ] weird yeah I
mean it's not like you're out here on in
k-town sitting on a bench eating a can
of beans [ __ ] through a [ __ ]
bench like by the way it doesn't
actually did see and so like that's that
type of weird right there's also the
weird that just attention seeks all the
time it's just really corny just [ __ ]
just a cornball of [ __ ] right but you're
just you're just a quirky weird like
you're different that's all you know
what I mean so that's a good winner I
like weird people
everybody in Jake Kane's weirdest [ __ ]
you think Joe is normal no Joe is weird
that came out too fast Joe I'm so like
Joe is like the most fun type of weird
dude I've ever met yeah this
[ __ ] like he has but he's also
smart as [ __ ]
well that's what I'm saying like he has
his he Joe so funny to meet Joe we'll
have a conversation and he'll do things
that he expects us to know but nobody in
human earth will understand what's going
on like he'll say some [ __ ] and he'll be
like yep drawers in the air and he goes
and then he goes get it I'm sorry what
did you just do because I just wrote my
words out yep
[ __ ] how the [ __ ] are we supposed to
know what they should you do to hear
halfway through so I only caught the
last syllable of the word and the only
reason why I knew it was like a in
Phatak because I saw him draw the
exclamation mark and you know what the
head motion would come - yep
and that's who Joe is you know I mean
and that's a really weird type of weird
Bart's [ __ ] weird - I say like the
most normal person in the [ __ ] group
to be honest which you would probably be
like the girls liked if I Gio is pretty
normal she's pretty like you know just
normal nothing really out there and same
thing with TIFF you know well you didn't
see the JK news girls thing
the scenes yeah y'all were drinking
that's a little different though right
was [ __ ] sipping on some either they
were like ladies and I was like and you
know also just because like we you know
what I was saying last time about like
you know it was so cold you know except
for them to be like ladies the bottle
we're going to Bali next week I was like
is this what having a group of
girlfriends is supposed to be like all
like this you signed up with the wrong
[ __ ] company I know you know I I
still like you I I still got to be
grateful you know of course but fuck'em
the moment where we looked at each other
and I was like I'll say this though you
know I heard Smosh like the two guys are
from Sacramento or like a part of them I
heard they're from like Natomas though
Natomas is a bunch of rich white people
so I never I was never allowed there
like I think I tried to go in there was
a force field that bounced me right back
out know what the [ __ ] I started miming
towards initially the [ __ ] is this I met
one dude he was only there for a while
and like I didn't know it was when I
first joined that he was about to leave
and like I didn't really know him that
well but that dude was like always in
his head so like I should have known
some [ __ ] was about to go down like we'd
be on a shooting the hugest he's sitting
there and they'd be like Anthony Oh like
like it was yeah there was a lot going
on there and like I because they were uh
I remember they had a do they have a
movie on Netflix yeah they had I think
they had like two movies but I mean
that's how it goes once something is a
sellable IP they're like put it on a
lunchbox sell it ship it stick it on my
dick like with like whatever I think I
tried watching it and then I shoot ride
with David goodbye yeah well I like I
turned it on and then I started watching
it and then I took my TV I threw out the
window
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] bad and I think
that was like one of the first
introduction that I had to Smosh
because I knew of Smosh but I never saw
anything Smosh did and so I was like yo
for me like I may sound like a [ __ ]
hater but I will say this when I see a
youtuber succeed and then go to another
platform it makes me happy because now
it's like to the rest of mainstream
media is I suck my [ __ ] nuts [ __ ]
that's true you said we couldn't do it
well guess what here's the u2
that showed [ __ ] facts man and so
when I saw the Smosh I know they're
youtubers so [ __ ] yeah I gotta support
the [ __ ] right that's you know I was
seeing about that the other day because
I saw a poky main she's a twitch
streamer and like she I think she
started probably just a few months or a
few like a year before I did I saw her
on Amazon Prime I was like hell yeah
girl you go girl sure because like I'm
on this new thing now we're like I love
seeing people succeed yeah like before I
was just kinda like now actually no
before I was a [ __ ] hater David oh
really I was a hater I was a hey because
I was so miserable myself I need
everyone to be miserable with me and now
that like I'm happy and pretty chill
like I love seeing people succeed and I
know how it feels when people support me
when I'm doing well in something and so
I'm like I want to do that for everyone
yeah and to that credit to light like
iLike I just mentioned just because I
don't like the [ __ ] that you do doesn't
mean I'm not supporting what you're
doing there's a lot of youtubers out
there who I think their product is
absolute hot flaming garbage yes like a
parade doesn't mean that reflects on you
as a human being though like I'm allowed
to have an opinion on the art that you
put out same thing with me you could
listen to this podcast and be like yo
that guy David I don't get him I don't
think he should be successful that's
cool just don't be disrespectful to me
that's yeah like leave it you know it's
like I posted it to the other day
because like so many people there's like
a bandwagon where people like to hate on
a Jojo see wha
you know the the girl with the ponytail
she's a she's like a younger youtuber is
she I think she's like 16 or 17 he's
like [ __ ] six foot ten
I heard a convention one time I thought
she was on stilts she's huge but she
dresses like a ten year old because
that's her bread and that's her audience
and people are like don't you think it's
creepy that Jojo does this does it like
she's just making content like she's
just making content and they don't know
how to transition her yet it's like all
business shut the [ __ ] up in mind your
business yeah like there it's like
there's this weird thing where people
think that all content should be for
them otherwise it's garbage oh yeah man
they just want they just want the shoot
if it only on them oh yeah you know yeah
it's all about and that's the weird
thing too like I I had to learn that
[ __ ] too though you know you know
because like we're not like okay let me
just to be real like I probably was a
hater to when I first came in because I
started I came from traditional stand-up
right so I wanted to be a stand-up comic
and then everybody was doing this
YouTube [ __ ] and I was like
[ __ ] wet this is so stupid dude and
mind you like the first person that I
saw who I actually really enjoy I mean
he seems like a really dope person right
I don't really like his videos but I
seem like a really cool person but the
first video that I saw somebody doing
comedy was actually Shane Dawson and it
was in my sociology class in college and
they were showing a new media but when
it was just starting to pop off yeah and
they and I at this time I didn't know
that on YouTube you could create video
content I thought you just it was
somebody else who uploaded all this
random [ __ ] I don't know that you could
be a content creator on there and I saw
Shane Dawson on there and I saw his
stuff as I wore this white boy is not
funny and I was like I could do this
better you know and that was just me
being competitive at the time right
right wait but it's what propelled you
exactly I know until this day spite is a
thing that drives my engine so it's the
fuel you know spite is the fuel for me
you know like like sometimes I'll have
like a bad conversation or somebody will
say some [ __ ] and then I'll get all in
my head and I'll get sad and I'm like
nah like that fire baby let's [ __ ] go
hey yo you know what's funny - cuz
especially like you know with the film
that I did [ __ ] like we did this film
and it got into Sundance and everything
else right yeah so I did this film and
people you know when I was at Sundance
people were asking like oh so what was
the motivation for this film was because
you don't see a lot of Asian faces on
this stuff as I'm in my mind like when I
in the interview I said of course like I
want to support my Asian brothers and
sisters like I want to be wewe can act
that's not it it was a completely petty
thing I wanted to be signed by a bunch
of acting agencies right and they
wouldn't sign me because they got burned
by a lot of [ __ ] new media people who
would have show up to their auditions
they thought they were better than these
auditions would you mind you that's fine
you could think that but just don't get
signed to an agency and not go right and
so I got burned and nobody would sign me
so I was like oh you think I can't act
[ __ ] you I'm gonna make a movie that was
damn yourself ya know that's and like
that's you ascending from the okay I was
talking to somebody about this the other
day so the whole influencer thing yeah I
don't influence her that's a title the
Hollywood gave us to not let us be
celebrities yeah even though so [ __ ]
that's some [ __ ] uh yeah
and and then we just accepted it we were
like yeah that's what we are but why is
you know god amanda cerny has like 20
million followers she's bigger than a
lot of TV stars right now she's no
matter what she's an influencer she's
not a celebrity she's always an
influencer Hollywood gave us that name
and we were like thank you thank you
Father
yeah yeah and now you it's so hard to
break out of the title influencer and I
think that you've actually broken that
mold but a lot of people haven't and a
lot of people won't because you have to
step outside of you have to step outside
of your circle and some people won't
step outside of their circle because
that's not getting them numbers and
recognition yeah matter and you know to
that too like I always tell people it's
like well they're like okay I'm gonna do
movies like who says you have to you
don't have to do a [ __ ] movie it's a
different craft it's it's it's probably
not your [ __ ] lane and it probably
wasn't mine I just did something out of
spite I'm picturing you like naked
wrapped up in a blanket but you know
what solve it like film you know what
it's probably I put that on myself I put
myself but negative plenty of blankets
sheets for no goddamn reason so no but
you have you seen but I'll show you some
Instagram post so I did this whole Syria
yo so I did this whole [ __ ] so I did
this whole [ __ ] series where I uh
we're all just making fun of Instagram
girls and so basically like basically
any basic [ __ ] that will put up a post
that has nothing to do with whatever
[ __ ] like social justice cause that
they're supporting but they're half
naked with a [ __ ] out and so I did my
version of that [ __ ] and I did like 12
photos and because I'll come do a
calendar I did do it so it's I put every
photo out on Instagram but it's pretty
[ __ ] scandalous like I did some wild
[ __ ] and I gotta tell you man like I'll
probably never do it again but it was
during the time where I was like 260
pounds - so is ten times more funny I
was cracking the [ __ ] up while I was
doing it and I just remember I when I
first thought when I put the first photo
out right it was me like up against his
blue wall
this blue wall here and then I had so
there was a picture of a girl who put
put on her jeans backwards where the ass
is in the front and the zippers on the
back and she's shown her ass crack so I
did that photo okay and I was but [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] I lost like 2,000
followers
I lost 2k followers with a quickness
[ __ ] homophobe against bug like
y'all are tourists to us [ __ ] when I
watch it then [ __ ] I'm trying to think
of what what I've done what I've done to
lose the most amount of followers in one
swoop this podcast was one for me this
podcast was a hugely I lost like 8,000
followers all that god damn you
[ __ ] hate me subscribe yeah
yeah it's not a big deal but I'm kind of
like damn dude but they're also you know
anyone that actively goes out of their
way to unfollow a channel quite happy
like let's think about that that's like
going to write a yelp review for a
restaurant there was four stars yeah
it's fine let it be exactly no there are
channels that I'm subscribed to right
now I don't want to see any [ __ ] from
them it's not like the [ __ ] algorithm
works anyways and I'm seeing their stuff
anyways [ __ ] YouTube you [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah the [ __ ] matter that's
so wild that like you're a very
fascinating person like you're so
determined I didn't even know it now
it's honestly you know what like it's so
wack but like now I know I didn't know
that before in like it's like it's like
I've been through so much [ __ ] like in
my life just like I've been through like
a lot of [ __ ] and I beat myself up for
so long that like and that's why I'm
still thankful for the experience of
Smosh because I was I was clinically
depressed for like twenty years
yeah like horribly horribly like since I
was a kid and when you spend so much of
your life like and everything is gray
you don't even know what it looks like
to be to be happier for thing to bits
for things to be in full Technicolor and
so when I came out to LA and I joined
this company everything was suddenly in
Technicolor like no matter what problems
I had or you know you know awkwardness
or you
friendships that weren't really
establishing things were so much
different than me sitting in my room
streaming video games from midnight
until 8 a.m.
everything was in Technicolor so for
that I am forever grateful but how do
you play games like yo look it is taking
so much for me to get up from apex
legends to come on this podcast my black
castles up at 5 a.m. the other day on
the kill board almost late to work I was
up at 5 a.m. to play hours for to play
games for three hours before work how do
you do that and then have a career dude
you're a fascinating human being my god
David stop that's crazy
there's some times where I'm so [ __ ]
horny all I have to do is jackoff and
fall asleep I just said that I'm just
like you can do it David I'm like you
know what bro it's not worth it oh you
got a [ __ ] why should I do all this I
just knocked the [ __ ] out yeah that's
what I'm saying that's what I think
that's the type of laziness I have no
you are not you are not you are so you
are not [ __ ] late don't you [ __ ]
ever say you're [ __ ] lazy I am I feel
like a piece of [ __ ] next to you you
understand look and the other thing is I
have a standard for myself I have a
standard for my line my needs okay
people think I'm joking right they're
like oh what do you do when YouTube
explodes I already told you I'm sucking
dick oh my god I had that when I was
like I was going through it over the
other day I got so sad David because I
was going through Skid Row and like I
always wanted to see Skid Row because
it's like you know for people that don't
live in LA it's just it's another world
it's a couple's and I've heard that it's
a couple streets of just like people are
homeless like streets and streets and
streets and so like I had never seen
Skid Row before and I was so curious
about this cuz in Virginia where I live
there's not really a lot of homelessness
like at all you know and so like it was
it was just interesting and I've heard
so much about it so like I drove by like
the other day and I saw on the map I was
like the first time you saw Skid Row yes
dawg and you know what I was surprised
by there are so many women yeah there
are so many women and they're like
attractive women and I'm like yes get
bro to like what
lot of people don't know like
specifically for me because I
volunteered at Skid Row like
Thanksgiving a [ __ ] given out whatever
you give him socks I lose food so I was
doing all the food stuff they need more
than Jesus but maybe the prayer they
need some holy water and an ice bath but
like you know I'm not knocking on the
homeless there what I'm saying is that
what people don't know about Skid Row
when we tell these stories on JK news
about like homeless people right and oh
that's not what all homeless people are
like I didn't say all homeless people
Mitch go to Skid Row and you'll know
what I'm talking about like we tell
these story yeah I'm talking about I saw
a dude right who was black man black
male that was flinging around nunchucks
right I was like oh what the [ __ ] is
dudes in the broad daylight fleeting
nunchucks of [ __ ] dude it was like it
wasn't even nunchucks it was like
kielbasa
he was just swinging around like
nunchucks yo how am I not supposed to
laugh at that that's just [ __ ] wild
man if one of those sausages flew off in
the street and got run over my car he's
so upset I mean that's why I have a
collection of diseased random things I
saw it's Skid Row there was a dude that
I saw just rocking at the edge of a curb
as I'm pumped as about the pump and get
gas so there's this part on it's like
Alameda if you go it's like a it's a
virile gas station there's just rocking
back and forth he just goes I got so
[ __ ] scared I don't even know why my
zipper was down but I was it that [ __ ]
right hella right into my [ __ ] cars
and I'm out of here
I don't even pump guess I'll just gonna
risk it like [ __ ] I don't [ __ ]
know it's like he scared my zipper down
I was like no I think he was talking to
me he was like I'm talking to you there
Dublin from my whole [ __ ] he said a lot
of things to me but they had like like
dude like skin Bros is different because
it's a drug situation so a lot of people
are Skid Row they're drug addicts right
so we're not talking about people who
are just you know I'm there are people
like that yeah yeah I know but that's a
specific homeless area where there was a
huge like a couple years ago there was a
lot of deaths that were having a Skid
Row because there was a synthetic drug
that was made and they were passing it
around and everybody's trying to get
high and there's people just started
[ __ ] dying on Skid Row all the
homeless people because you know they're
they're junkies and they're addicted to
[ __ ] and it was it was something that
was supposed to be really good and
started killing people like that's the
type of dire situation there so I tell
you there's a man out there scooping the
[ __ ] out of his hand and smear against
the wall it's not a story I make it up
it's some real [ __ ] [ __ ] do it okay
if you if you were homeless what would
you do to get back on your feet I just
told you like okay you know with with
all with all the stuff that's been
happening and like I'm like holy [ __ ]
you know I have a career now like I have
an actual career and it's been so it's
been such a weight off my shoulders
because there's a question that all
women ask themselves at some point in
their life until they're all set up and
that's and that's am I gonna have to
suck some dick eventually to eat god
damn I've asked myself that question so
many times you did the hardest working
woman on earth but because it scared me
into working harder because I don't want
to have to suck dick to eat dinner I
don't want to do I know my mom's gonna
watch this podcast you know what the
crazy thing is I don't like like you
know like I feel like like I'm gonna
promise a lot for us before and they've
been like yeah I've had to think like
what if I had to do something if like I
didn't have my [ __ ] together and so like
you know when I got home from work one
day I was like oh that's the best
[ __ ] like t-shirt ever dude you gotta
have that [ __ ] cat on the [ __ ]
telephone line you know just like I
never had to suck dick for dinner never
had to suck dick for dinner you made it
way more cohesive but yeah that's that's
a real thing yeah I mean I feel like cuz
I know a lot of homegirls like this is
once per se her [ __ ] name but she's
really good she's really good at
finessing dudes right in the sense of
like this like you know she just worked
part-time job she likes to get drunk and
party whatever she was really fun friend
to have around but like with her like if
she just like [ __ ] I ain't gonna work
she just some find some dude and then
she would just [ __ ] date them bunk up
with them [ __ ] him and they will let her
stay and you know they were be in like a
relationship but she doesn't really like
him
she's just you know sugar daddy for the
moment like you would pay for a [ __ ] and
then she'd just get back on her feet get
another [ __ ] job start partying and
whatever use his money until you know he
got sick of her and she was so [ __ ]
good at that [ __ ] see guys don't got
that guys
we don't even have that option we don't
we don't have it oh you could definitely
suck somebody off for like yeah but the
money is nothing then the money's not
gonna be as good as yours my money's
gonna be bad like I'm pretty sure you
think your dick sucking market value is
the same as mine
my just in pesos like denarii I'm
talking about some old-fashioned money
like your your hope is that how low do
you see your [ __ ] dick sucking number
I mean kinda like as of right now if
people are watching this video and they
put an optioning bid for who whose dick
would be sucked by whose lips it's
definitely not gonna be mine oh yeah I
remember when I was in like fifth grade
somebody told me I had dsls and like you
know I'm a child of the Internet
yeah like nine you got dick sucking lips
and I remember in fifth grade being like
[Laughter]
it's so funny with like when people talk
about big sucking lips cuz that's just a
funny joke that we say but the size of
the lip doesn't make doesn't make the
[ __ ] any better it does I have never
once in my life been like let me flatten
out what maximum coverage like as long
as you got some skin under here like
you're fine like you're absolutely fine
like that's what matters exactly get you
a girl with the overbite Thanks yeah
because she's got more upper lip space
Nick yeah thank y'all by the walk around
[ __ ] LA be like [ __ ] you got that
overbite yeah you look so good
what you mean know why I like me oh they
love me I love that so you've been
watching me for quite a while
why do you say you ain't got dick suck
it you got that over by baby you gonna
you gonna graze the top of my dick
perfectly fine with that big-ass upper
lip you all gums and all over oh god you
I call you juicy fruit could use all
gums baby what's a think if there's I'm
trying to think of like all of my
friends that are good at it and like
what qualities they have and maybe it's
not physical
maybe it's mental I think you know
determination with lower self esteem
that feels like she's gotta like really
prove herself enthusiasm man I mean I'm
pretty sure you you already know this
too like when you or maybe you even know
girls like this whoo now they're getting
a little older and you know you're
seeing all their insecurities come out
because the girls who I know that
predicated everything about who they are
based on their looks they can't stand
aging right now they cannot stand it
nice and I'm seeing them crumble and
starting to like a little bit break my
heart a little bit because they have so
much to offer aside from their looks but
because of how people treated them based
on their looks they can't look past that
right they just see oh look at this
look at this that nobody [ __ ] cares
and also you're like a 35 year old woman
you're supposed to age a little bit you
still look [ __ ] amazing
yeah and they they didn't like some of
them because they got by so much on
their looks it was like not not saying
it was intentional but it was like why
enhance yourself in other areas why work
on yourself further you know I like I
always thought I was so [ __ ] ugly but
like now like I don't work I don't even
wear like makeup I have on like mascara
and like a little bit eyebrows like I
used to wear a lot of foundation cuz I
have like terrible acne scars but then I
realize like the foundation is not gonna
fill in the craters that's it this is
what your girl looks like take it or
leave it but because I hated myself so
much I had to like I had to get funnier
I had to get good at video games I had
to have other things that made me better
no I'm telling you man like people who
were like the most [ __ ] up looking
when they were younger and they figured
out how to become prettier
they're the best right because if you
see some of these like girls and you're
like kill this girl because there's
girls who are pretty and they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] but there's also really
beautiful
I mean I'm probably I say a great
handful of the more beautiful women with
great personalities because nobody was
really born with this concept that they
were always beautiful unless somebody
told us them constantly exactly right
cuz I know some people come on like you
know these girls that were just busted
when they were younger and then you're
like you meet them now and they're like
well they're really pretty look at that
person now they still got their bus to
grow personality they same thing with
dudes they do that we're [ __ ] like
the dweeby nerdy like did it go a lot of
keep them so and then when they get
older they still have a better
personality because they had to work on
something outside their looks and they
kept all those great traits and it's not
and actually now that you say that I was
thinking on this the other day it's not
just women
it's dudes too why do you think you see
girls like pretty girls with really
attractive guys when they're like in
their 20s but then when they're like in
their 30s there's still with
good-looking dudes but it's not the jock
yeah it's not the hottest dude in the
room because we realized okay we need a
little bit more to go with this you know
my different phases were like okay I had
to date the guy that I thought was the
hottest because it was arm candy and it
was gonna make me feel better about
myself because I got him and then it was
okay I'll date the cute guy that's kind
of funny and now I'm like do you have a
job
this isn't two of a job do you do you
have a good personality and then we go
to the looks yo it's cuz of those looks
because they go like this you know and
people say they should too because of
this like look thing that causes that
once again like I mentioned before a
certain like type of like metric and
value they go oh I'm a dope person I
deserve somebody who looks better than
this person and that's what you think
when you're younger it's like oh I'm out
of this person's Lea you know and to
that like everybody felt that way when
they're younger and that's why when you
get older you mature it's like yeah like
of course we still want the person that
we're with to be attractive that's a
given
that's it's human [ __ ] nature right
peacocks choose [ __ ] other peacocks
because they're [ __ ] feathers are
nice and big and shine shite I said
shiny and bright you know and we have
still those type of animal instincts
right same thing when it comes to
somebody the way they look their weight
whatever right it's like a survival
instinct that's something that can't be
denied
here's the thing though because we're
smarter human beings we could put other
factors in
right because like for me I thought I
was gonna end up with a [ __ ] even number
one lights get a black girl number two
curvy latina or number three angry
Vietnamese girl that's all I thought
that's all I thought I was gonna end up
with right but I ended up with a very
cute Korean girl right just very spry
very sprightly super clean very innocent
very kind and I thought I was gonna end
up with just his [ __ ] spicy saucy
[ __ ] and I was like that's the type of
women that I like but it wasn't right
yeah because I put that limit on myself
I told myself that this is the type of
woman that I deserve or that I wanted
and wasn't the case it's not even my
[ __ ] type like I don't even know why
I thought that yeah yeah yeah I mean I
discovered a bit like you know I I
thought that I wanted the funny guy the
bla bla but he's like you know he's
funny cuz he's probably got problems and
I don't know if he's worked through them
or not
you know like and now I'm with somebody
that like oh my god we have the best
communication yeah like the
communications fantastic he's nice guys
good guy like you know good same sense
of humor not over-the-top like you know
I wanted somebody that like personality
wise was like at it like at in like for
craziness humor blah blah you know I got
somebody that was a little more toned
down but excelled in other areas yeah
and that and that's and I didn't know
that that's what I really wanted until
you know you got can't be with no
crazy-ass loud dude you already there
you have like to [ __ ] that's like two
suns smashing into each other what
happened I mean I've been there before
it was crazy I bet those fights were
crazy too because it's just too intense
people going at it like what the [ __ ]
was that like uh you know so you know
funny like my last relationship that
made me not date anyone for four years I
was dating I was dating this Korean dude
named Esteban from Argentina oh there's
a lot of Korean people in Argentina
Wow and so uh and his family his family
had moved from Korea to Argentina and
then for some reason they had to leave
Argentina and come to the US and they
were so mad about it and they never they
they would never like learn English and
they didn't like any the people here so
I had to learn Korean so that I could
speak to his mom and like watch like
shows with her and [ __ ] like that and
just be clear I I can read like hongo
like pretty well but I can't really
speak it anymore
Oh
that's [ __ ] what how could you ever
say that you're lazy no I used to love
learning languages like when I was in
high school the first language I started
learning was Vietnamese like I started
watching fitna meets the most [ __ ]
difficult language it's hard to speak
it's easy to learn because like what I
love about like Vietnamese and a lot of
Asian languages is that there's no
separate term for this that you're that
is it's just one thing for an object
over there right right and so that's
what I like but pronouncing it was very
difficult
you chose a language that sounds like
somebody talking while they're drinking
water I well you know why because I used
to watch this watch this show called no
beyond and it was like it was called
mystery person and so like they were did
you watch Paris by night too cuz no I
did it what is that Paris by night is
like it's like Vietnamese Grammys that
they have is in Vegas they had the show
in Vegas no like it's so funny to so Joe
actually based one of his characters
uncle Chen off of a character that was
in Paris by night and Paris by night was
like a music concert like Grammys thing
that would happen like 17 times a year
it's like it's so good oh you got
watched no dude that's like it's the
best show I don't know why they didn't
ring into America yeah let me tell you
the concept all right so it's a show
where they have like these five judges
and then they put three people on stage
and they say one person is a flame
thrower and so they have to ask the
three people different questions and
they have to figure out who's actually
the mystery person home like really
doesn't do it and it's just so
outlandish it'll be like some crazy [ __ ]
like somebody that used to be a Russian
spy and they like won't look anything
like I love this so yeah I used to watch
that show a lot and so I just decided I
wanted to learn Vietnamese and then I
really like learning languages and stuff
so what are you fluent in any of them no
I just started learning them as a hobby
I started doing Spanish like six months
ago cuz I thought that it would be like
tactical and I just didn't enjoy it so I
just never something you have to enjoy
it yep or it's damn near impossible to
learn and you you also have to use it
otherwise you just completely lose it's
just mad useful here though I could have
used it today somebody was help me move
my bed to my place and I wanted to like
talk to him so bad because he looked so
friend
but he didn't speak any English just
like see I got a see like I see like I
know how to [ __ ] do like an East LA
accent but that's not gonna help I can't
be up to his eye a bottle just put it in
the [ __ ] corner and [ __ ] a yeah I
wish that I learned it so that I could
like speak to me by I just yeah I can't
and then also the thing is I loved
learning languages but when you actually
came to speaking to somebody I would get
so shy I gotta let go that [ __ ] yeah cuz
I've I've been reading books on how to
learn languages and apparently that's
one of those things yeah I have to let
me every single like forum that I've
read this and you have to get rid of
that notion that you're gonna sound and
look stupid cuz you are that's you just
have to accept that but people will
correct you and then you move on
so for me I'm supposed to learn Japanese
by this year and I was supposed to start
in January first it is now almost March
you need help dog like I need to learn
Japanese like hi because well Muriel
speaks Japanese so she speaks Japanese
Korean Mandarin and English oh yeah
fluently and she could I think she could
also read it right in all of them yes
dude I would be down to learn Japanese I
will write I want I want to go to Japan
and then just [ __ ] well for me what
did look Japanese but see for you I want
you to scare the [ __ ] out of somebody
yeah there's I go what the [ __ ] but they
do have a lot of like people in Japan
that are like mixed-race and it just
shocks the [ __ ] out of them yeah like
it's put your Japanese sighs no you're
like what 5 to 5 I came in with oh
that's right you're like a Japanese
basketball player dude down [ __ ] bite
sizes [ __ ] I know I think that's why I
haven't a pullian complex that's why I'm
so loud
oh maybe I got a make up for my short
stature cuz you know like tiny girls
like we we like we're loud we're very
like dominant tell men there's like
there's this one girl back in Sacramento
I mean we're still friends to this day
she's a little Vietnamese no names to
yet this [ __ ] [ __ ] in high school
used to be so [ __ ] loud she's a lot
more mellow now but she was so [ __ ]
loud and so physically aggressive like
like we would cloud on her for a little
bit and she would full-on throw blows at
us
big-ass Bob did she think she would
think it's funny because she's small but
she got [ __ ] bricks for fists and I'm
waking up the next day like bruise it
looks like I was in an abusive
relationship my dad's like where'd you
get those bruises I can't tell this from
a [ __ ] little bit nummies girl
alright would you get that from this
[ __ ] guy you know look I came out now
is that what's good could I start
throwing games on it huh
not anymore she's a lot more mellow but
to get cracks me up t at if you ever
watch this I'm not making fun of you but
I kind of am I'm yet this goes so
[ __ ] funny in high school so T yet
she has like a bit of an accent like she
she has invented me the accident or
whatever right I'm not even sure have
enemies accent per se but it's a little
bit of I don't want to say it's a speech
impediment but it kinda is I've never
heard anybody referred to an accident
like I'm sort of thing like you know
sometimes my like southern accent kind
of I do yet doesn't sound like this
she's not sounded like hey what the hell
man so you want to go eat some food
label like never seen you long time no
see like she's not saying that type of
[ __ ] like you know she's not she's not
doing that you know what I mean but I
think it's because like in her household
they speak mainly Vietnamese but
obviously when she goes to school
everybody speaks English so she never
got to learn both languages very well so
she's a man without a land so she
doesn't have like so she basically you
know I heard that her Vietnamese her
accent is great but she's not very she's
it's not prolific as it should be for
somebody who doesn't speak English as
well but this [ __ ] in high school man
like I remember like I could not I
hadn't high already had trouble
understanding her then and so when we
were in school we were learning
something about immigration and I talked
this [ __ ] we were we were at lunch and
then we were and they were people gonna
know that I was an immigrant that I
wasn't born here like my first language
was Korean and then I became a citizen
like maybe like ten years ago yeah so we
were all talking and they were like yo
so you know David when you come to
America I came in I was like two and a
half years old three years old or
whatever something like that and oh cool
cool and I looked at two yet as itea
when did you come to America she looks
like me she goes David so I was born
here
and first of all I thought she was
joking right
so I [ __ ] laughed at her face like
she told the funniest joke
I thought she was being funny so I
waited I started dying laughing like I
was cracking the [ __ ] up and she goes
Davis on see I was born you know
everybody always says my full name
hey David so I was I was born here and I
was like [ __ ] you are so [ __ ] funny
I'll [ __ ] out here you and your jokes
what you talkin about you were born she
was I was born and then my friend Phoebe
she grabs me she goes David she was
actually born you're actually hurting
her feelings and then you would think
that would get me to stop but I couldn't
stop laughing because of how how much I
embarrass myself in her face and lo and
behold as I was walking this [ __ ]
socked me and threw me into a bush this
girl would not stop putting hands on me
dude like if she was a guy we would have
traded blows why she was so fat she was
so [ __ ] physically aggressive I [ __ ]
you not
I once saw my friend in his white Honda
Accord he ran from one side to the other
and he [ __ ] WWF dropkick beside the
other side of the door because she
wouldn't leave his car like she's that
type of aggressive like people would
drop kick her like it's nothing you'll
shout out the tea as much time you want
because I got one more story tell me oh
yeah yo so check this out so no we were
we were on twatter right we were on the
Twitter's right and I read this tweet
that just [ __ ] number one it made me
laugh and number two had me mad
irritated and it was basically you know
I'm gonna let you tell the [ __ ] story
because it's so ridiculous I'm gonna
tell the backstory
okay noise I wish I could type all this
out but I did so so I told you that I
work with like a lot of like you know
attorneys yeah yeah there's a there's a
group of like newer attorneys they're
basically like the baby lawyers they
throw parties and like mixers and stuff
so this [ __ ] makes me so mad okay okay
so so it's the first mixer and remember
I've been at this company for like a
little over two
once now I want to say yeah and I'm
running the marketing department but we
don't have an individual like social
media person and so I'm like well I know
that these events have you know 80 to
100 people that attend
I need those [ __ ] pictures and I'm
gonna go there drink be merry take the
pictures get paid get out you know yeah
so um I get there and I sit down and I'm
like I'm early
like I'm like 30 minutes early so I
start setting up I have to put the sign
up it's like you know Fattah you know
the legal [ __ ] like photography will be
used for this if you enter you you
consent yeah I'm setting up and then I I
you know I get a glass of wine order
some food and I'm chilling and and then
the people start rolling in yeah and I
cart I start rolling around like walking
around and like snapping some pictures
and like none of my pictures really
looked good and it was kind of dark in
there and that's when it hit me I was
like damn I gotta ask people like hey
can you pose for a picture and like you
know I'm used to like me you know
somebody like post you know me or
something yeah and then Soleil and I'm
also like kind of I'm kind of like I
don't wanna say a shy person but like I
don't know how to approach people that I
don't know I'm afraid of rejection so
it's hard for me to approach people that
I don't know you know somebody I'm
comfortable with I'm like you know but
you know so so I'm sitting there at the
table and I start looking around I'm
like [ __ ] I gotta like talk to some
people and I see this group of girls and
they're like real they're really
good-looking like they have a great look
for camera they would be perfect for
like holding their drinks I'm like oh I
having a nice time and so like I'm
awkward and I'm nervous and I think
maybe I showed weakness so I sat there
for a second and I was like um damn I
gotta talk to them I gotta talk to them
no don't no don't and then I was like no
just get up on this [ __ ] do your job get
your pictures like this [ __ ] ride and
so I get up and I was like I was like
hey can I get a picture of you guys to
her social media and then this girl
looked at me and she was like can you
and excuse me I was like David it in my
head the situation was gonna play out oh
yes pose next group of people and so
like I just [ __ ] wait her response
was oh can you as if she's a [ __ ]
annoying teacher I can you what do you
mean can you [ __ ] you try to get
[ __ ] cut oh no it gets worse
and so I'm at that point I have my
confidence was shattered I crumbled
because I was not expecting that so I go
to what I've done for the past 20 years
I go to comedy and so I just say yeah if
I click this button I can that's though
and so I'm like you know that's that's
that's my save right and so then she's
like um yeah you can take our picture
and she's this one is the prettiest one
out of all of them right and she's a kid
you can take my picture but I'm a
headhunter can you tag my or she's like
I'm a headhunter is that okay and I'm
just like I don't I was like I don't
know what that is and then this other
girl likes me and she's like you don't
know what a headhunter is she's like
it's a basically a person that tries to
steal lawyers from other firms and bring
them to another firm and they get the
referral fee and I was like oh okay
because like you know I'm working for
like a firm and like an organization so
I'm like oh the old [ __ ] and so I just
say oh I don't know the protocol for
that and she was like really
what can you tag my headhunting firm is
that can you do that and I'm just like
kind of just like backed into a corner
at this zone that's when you [ __ ] get
a [ __ ] glass of red wine and you're
[ __ ] splash it okay I'm not even
gonna let me let me just tell you real
number one by the voice that you use she
sounds el Blanco okay cuz that sounds
like some El Blanco [ __ ] for you people
out there that don't know Spanish broken
Spanish that's white with a capital H
you know I'm sayin
cuz that's like some like hoity-toity
I'm better than you type a [ __ ] yeah
does she not know that her people owe
you reparations a little spice in her
but for the most part yes and like she
was like she was very attractive didn't
suck what you look like [ __ ] you don't
talk to me like that I will slash your
[ __ ] tires and tell you the neighbor
did a [ __ ] [ __ ] so like at this point
I'm just broken yeah okay like I'm like
I did not expect this conversation to go
this way and it's just taking a hard
left and so like I'm very nervous and so
like I kind of get quiet for a second
and I'm processing and I didn't say this
but I look at them and I'm like oh
they're pretty this makes sense they're
not attorneys they're supposed to be hot
so that they get the attorneys and so in
I had I'm like yeah they're definitely
headhunters and then she just like and
she's still looking at me and she's like
you're not an attorney are you and I oh
oh now we try to be classy
you know you try to put me in a category
like I'm not worth your [ __ ] time
Oh David it gets worse has the [ __ ]
ever got backhanded with some [ __ ]
baby powder before dude that's what I
said I think I showed weakness cuz I
should have been able to handle this
you know you knowing like after
something bad happens you're in the
shower you actually you know I played
that I woke up at 4:00 a.m. after this
happened in a cold sweat so so that so
that she's like you're not an attorney
are you and I was like oh I was like no
I'm in marketing and she said oh so
you're just here to take our photos and
and that's when I short-circuited and I
was like and I turned around and I sat
back at my table and here's the worst
part David how you don't know somebody
talked to you like that III broke I
completely broke noted over the years so
we're getting there so but the worst
part about it is when I turn around to
sit at my table the tables were this
style they were like benches so my table
was about four inches so when I turn
back around
i sat literally basically next to her at
a table with like this much space away
and I was just staring at my glass of
wine and I was like so these were the
first people I had approached to take
pictures and almost like oh my god and
so I was just like [ __ ] traumatized
so then some other girl was really nice
and like came over and like talked to me
for a while and then um and then later
on this guy that was like the president
of the young lawyers whatever he had
come over and talked to me and he was
like oh you had a fantastic presentation
today I want you to meet these people
and I looked over and I could see this
[ __ ] and I was like you hear this you
know you hear that [ __ ] great white
[ __ ] great why would you [ __ ] is jagged
ass tape and you pointed out noise you
[ __ ] anglo-saxon [ __ ] dude so that is
what happened before that
so for y'all that don't know so that was
it for that interaction so the infirmary
there was three girls so the one was the
real real [ __ ] one and then she had
another friend and just because they
just wanted to put that little that
little sizzle that little [ __ ]
nail in the coffin to [ __ ] me up when
they were like leaving I was standing
there talking to somebody and she just
pulls my shoulder back and she was like
um can you can you delete any photos
that you have of me she touched you oh
yeah she pulled my [ __ ] you do not okay
first of all let's just let's just put
this as a precursor if you put your
hands on somebody that you don't know
and it's not in a friendly way expect to
get the [ __ ] cat claws I'm saying I'm
saying cat claws cuz I'm a little [ __ ]
you let me say I would say lion paws but
that's not gonna happen I got cat claws
you bought the game I really wish that I
would have just helped you yeah but what
you don't dad
dude I mean and she came at me so fast
she like pulled my shoulder back and she
was like um can you delete any photos
that you have on me that you guys are
posting I I have an agent and I usually
get paid for endorsements because I have
over 5,000 followers and I was like oh
five thousand 500 uses
you have five thousand followers you
don't know who the [ __ ] you were talking
to did you use five thousand followers
and I'm not I'm not knocking people who
worked towards having five thousand but
if you're somebody would bother we're
not like flash that and you're gonna be
rude to somebody with that and so it and
so okay so y'all don't know but this is
how the conversation went cuz I had to
convince it for Twitter I said oh okay I
was like it's kind of dark in here can I
have your social media tag so that I can
identify you in photos yeah and then she
gave me her tag and I said okay I'll
drop you a follow - yeah like you guys
don't know like I have I have like like
I think like 160,000 followers or
something like that like but and so like
I and I don't I don't care about that
[ __ ] yeah but in this situation it
matters it had to be done
this was God's work I had to do it so so
after she left I never followed somebody
so goddamn fast in my [ __ ] life
so I and so just so I followed her on
the firm's account and I followed her on
my account just so like you didn't look
so it looked a little more friendly like
yeah
oh yeah you know yeah and I liked it
overnight and then the next morning I
woke up and I got scared because like
she's like she's connected I I was
afraid that she was gonna like call my
boss and make some petty [ __ ] up or do
that so I ended up I'm following her but
I know she saw that [ __ ] and also to be
fair she had 7200 followers
Oh 7200 so that allows you to be a [ __ ]
Pipo but I know she saw it
I know course she saw it she did she
pulled out that number saying look not
only am i a headhunter right I'm not
only am i a [ __ ] headhunter which by
the way [ __ ] that means you're also not
a [ __ ] lawyer you cut back she
actually was she was an attorney like
she said to me like afterwards she was
like no I am just kidding I am an
attorney like she was just being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know so why did you
not put hands on her that happens you
call me up right cuz I still got a
little boob let's I just gotta I just
gotta push brother [ __ ] up and I got a
long [ __ ] wig and I'm putting hands
on her face like boom and she's like who
are you you [ __ ] big [ __ ] I'm a UFC
fighter ho like what's good and I still
got my balls [ __ ] my favorite I fell in
foxhole my favorite thing about this was
the Geo Gina
everybody like because we have a group
chat like I have a group chat that we
like talk about [ __ ] and everybody came
down they were like bows who is this
[ __ ] and I was like if I was petty
enough we were all about to come down on
her like every single one of us just go
I just was waiting I'm like a picture yo
I'm talking about people like that have
never been checked in their life and
people like that also grew up in a way
where everybody treated them special
because they think that their [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't stink
they think that they [ __ ] [ __ ]
diamonds well guess what [ __ ] bullets
don't discriminate
oh my god I'm saying Oh backhand feel
the same way on everybody's [ __ ] left
cheek you [ __ ] dumb ho oh this is
what I'm saying like this is that's the
exact type of person I [ __ ] hate like
never once in my life have I ever flexed
that I had certain fun but one time I
actually flexed on it when I flexed on a
[ __ ] 80 year old grandpa that was
fixing my camera right so this is what
happened let me tell you this I've used
my [ __ ] following Alexa [ __ ] hard
I wanted this dude out in the k-town
area that fixes cameras and stuff right
really sweet dude but he has this really
dope camera shop that has a lot of
vintage [ __ ] and I wanted to take a
picture of it now this is amazing and so
I whip out my camera to take a photo so
this is awesome cuz I was gonna give him
a five-star yelp review which I don't do
Yelp right
cuz I was trying to do good deed but he
just comes up to me and he goes excuse
me sir do I do I just walk into your
house and start taking photos and I
looked at him and I was like yo that's
the [ __ ] that popped in my head I was
like oh I have at this time I was like I
have like 200,000 followers I was just
gonna give you you know like good press
like it's you know cuz I wanted to take
the photo of its place because it looks
so awesome and he goes does it look like
I care
I was like yeah photos I'm like mmm this
man has a point yeah you know like dude
we live in a little social media bubble
we're like you know like we we are I
almost said woke but is there a better
word than woke awake we are we are awake
if we know that that [ __ ] doesn't matter
but then there's still some people that
are trapped in a bubble and some people
forget that there's this other community
that doesn't give a [ __ ] how many
followers you have yep they don't give a
[ __ ] the one time I used it was on an 80
year old man because I like the way he
fixed my cameras and all the only reason
why is I just wanted to take a photo of
his place cuz I liked it too give him a
yelp review yeah I flex on that [ __ ]
hard though yeah you sure you didn't
flex hard enough though how would a
[ __ ] flex so [ __ ] hard t-shirt what
it came off that she would have tore up
in a million shreds oh they say I
crumbled I really did too i sir - yes
I'm a headhunter oh my oh my god you
suck dick hmm hmm I've been slapped by
friends but not not like in a
confrontation okay yeah cuz there's a
lot of people that I believe have never
been slapped before I've been slapped
before that [ __ ] has never missed
laughs dude yeah no I actually funny
story I got into like I remember I got
ins when I was like 13 I was at the
arcade right and there was this girl
was Luisa she she still follows me on
Instagram we cool now he was but uh she
should we were in the arcade and like we
had some beef on MySpace and like I was
walking away and she was like I thought
so and like hard are like she was she
was latina and she hit me with a car
right and so and guess what I did David
I turned around I was like what the [ __ ]
did you say [ __ ] what I hit her well
David next thing you know I was on the
ground and Lisa had taken her metal
bangle bracelet and flipped it over her
fist and was hitting me repeatedly
was Luisa born in a prison I did she
also did she did she did the [ __ ] also
[ __ ] squeeze out a shank out her puss
like duh it was it was a plastic
bracelet so how old was she like seven
we were dude we were like 12 13 14 13
that [ __ ] was born in prison her father
also has cell face tattoos that that's
not a normal [ __ ] [ __ ] well you know
what I learned from that is that you can
call me whatever you want no just
capable her name is Louisa that's not
like a big [ __ ] - yeah but I mean it
was the bracelet man it was the bracelet
and I remember mall security pulled us
apart and I remember the security guard
said he was like well I guess we know
who won that fight you naming your
[ __ ] latina child Louisa is like
naming your white girl [ __ ] Bertha
yeah I mean you really know what the
[ __ ] that was a sarong that's a strong
[ __ ] Big Bertha lazy Louisa they they
were like let's take the name Lewis and
make it feminine you know what you do
with people though like that that one
[ __ ] lawyer right that acts super
smart so this is what I used to do I
don't do it anymore now I just let
things slide but I act I try to act as
dumb as possible so they can educate me
on stuff and had them constantly
explained things to me so for example if
she goes you don't know what a
headhunter is and I'd be like have you
ever had a situation because I normally
like up quick like alright yeah you know
I'm
[ __ ] I'm ready to go but like yeah
I've had that like I couldn't process
what was going on and then after I
processed it I'm like hold on a second I
just got I just got slightly it's got
finesse yeah somebody [ __ ] just gave
me the [ __ ] French glove back hand to
the face and that's only after but
usually when somebody comes at me like
they're smart and they're better than me
then I [ __ ] show up where it's like
yeah I become the bumpkin and I just
happen to try to explain things to me
like for example this is just a quick
story there's this dude that my manager
introduced me to his [ __ ] guy slicked
back hair [ __ ] sweater around his
neck tucked in shirt he worked for like
an insurance company and he was he was a
co-worker of his dude on you name Malik
and so the guy just he's already here
just talking about his his [ __ ] fancy
[ __ ] world he grew up in to mind you
when I first came to LA I was super
confrontational like hyper
confrontational and so the guy just
comes up and he goes oh you know I've
just been traveling across the world he
goes I went to uh was it was a beer fest
or what I shouldn't what's that sugar
[ __ ] yeah Oktoberfest yeah Oktoberfest
he goes he goes oh I went to Oktoberfest
and I was like what's dad and he goes
you know what Oktoberfest is in Germany
outside there's like Germany the country
and I was like I don't I don't know
saying and then my man is literally
punching me in the leg he's like stop
yeah he told me to stop right because
you know he's introducing me these
people you know they have a lot of money
I was like okay well I'm traveling a lot
to different worlds like you know it's
really opened up my mind and stuff
you're like well when you get there
you'll probably do it too as a kid where
he goes he goes where I met Germany
they're just constantly doing this and
he's getting [ __ ] irritated and the
whole time he's this whole time he's
trying to tell stories to everybody
around the table after he just like talk
to me like I'm a peasant and I'm just
overly laughing and everything's that
he's doing so he's just telling a story
he'll just be like oh yes owe me a mic
like I have to because he treated me
like I was trash and I was like if
you're trying to embarrass me I can
embarrass I can out embarrass whatever
you're going to do to me and so like I
used to be that type of guy it's like if
you do something where you make me feel
like I'm beneath you
we got a [ __ ] problem oh yeah but you
could be disrespect when you call me fat
[ __ ] whatever that's fine
you treat me like I'm a class beneath
you that's when I get [ __ ] man is a
lot of personal [ __ ] with that you know
what I mean specifically number one I
didn't grow up with a lot of [ __ ]
money and I didn't realize how poor I
wasn't telling with the college because
everybody's poor I grew up yeah we just
were all broke [ __ ] kids didn't
[ __ ] matter there was no class issue
there but I went to college I first
experienced that [ __ ] unless she used to
make me mad and it brings up those type
of feelings so that whole [ __ ] dinner
I was just I was just riding his ass I
guess is that what is that is how to say
I was riding his [ __ ] ass riding
riding is dead I was in it I was playing
with the [ __ ] and the ridges on his but
I think that's a saying no yeah no I'm
in the same boat you know next time we
do this I got to start reading you some
of my [ __ ] emails from work because I
got some like I like I I do not tolerate
some stuff I you know like where I work
right now there's like a I've worked
some people who are occasionally they're
kind of more the outsource people they
like to make a lot of excuses and like
when you ask them something and they'll
just like make a bunch of excuses yeah
and then and then usually people respond
to their excuse and then they respond to
that with an excuse and I learned that I
just need to ask them the [ __ ]
question again yeah I mean like and then
it just and then it just all dissipates
so I have some very petty people shared
that one day I'm gonna see all that
shit's people are [ __ ] faccia
yeah we were talking for an hour and
[ __ ] half I know we could go on for
[ __ ] hard too I know but I'll tell
you this though beause you are welcome
anytime just because number one you and
I we [ __ ] chop it up I gotta tell you
there's a lot of people that come on JK
news and there's only a few people that
are hyper connect with and you're
definitely one of them yes [ __ ] it's
cuz I'm a real it's cuz we're authentic
people and I think that we feel that
like authenticity and so it's like like
when you speak I don't I don't have to
process anything that you say through a
filter you know I'm like what David
saying to me is exactly what he means
whereas some people I have to look for
their motive or why they're saying this
would be something you know and so like
we get to just talk in free flow I'm
pretty sure you might be like me to
where all of our group of friends like
the people that we connect with and we
[ __ ] with they're all different human
beings too like you can't really put us
into like a small group and say like
these people will probably hang out with
these type of people
yeah because the only [ __ ]
requirement that I have to connect with
somebody is that you have to be a
genuine honest person you could be a gay
or you could be this and I don't give a
[ __ ] as long as you're a real person and
then we we kind of get along and we get
along that's that's all that yeah it is
required because like you said I don't
want to figure out what your motives are
you're just you yeah and now I can make
the choice of whether I [ __ ] with you or
not you know I'm saying you invited
anytime yeah we gotta call this session
spill in the [ __ ] tape I love
the [ __ ] but anyways guys you guys could
check genius brain podcast on iTunes
casts box Spotify any kind of audio
platform out there go ahead give us a
thumbs up on the video share the [ __ ]
video share the audio stuff because
we're having more with these type of
conversations just because you know it's
[ __ ] fun and where can they find you
bozo bosey Instagram but look big boss
bows or on Twitter sometimes I talk [ __ ]
like like every two months I'll pop in
and like talk some [ __ ] follow on
Twitter it's hilarious